that's not the plan
Jayden I gotta ask you yeah do you have
to have thick skin
to be with this guy absolutely I mean
not even just thick skin maybe more so
like an understanding like it's a what's
the understanding that he just does
[Music]
like whatever he wants to do not even
just like that like he he's very I mean
it's not like he's saying oh I'm you're
just like my own like you know what I'm
saying he's in my ear tummy you're my
only girl or like or even just the next
but she's not saying that to them so
it's kind of like there's no cover it's
kind of like I mean either deal with it
or deal with it like this is what it is
you can either accept the circumstances
I mean yeah I mean I'm not gonna I'm not
the type of fish that's gonna sit accept
everything though yeah no obviously we
have I I get on his ass about a lot of
[__] don't get that Twisted at all but I
just I'm not gonna sit and harp on
about something that I can't change or I
was gonna say like because you guys were
out a lot together and then uh you had
to go perform with you had to go perform
at the zoo's thing right so is that
something that you're yeah I understand
you got to go get get your business
right right for Sean yeah I mean I mean
that was something that was also pre no
for sure that's already pre-scheduled
schedule so I mean I also give you happy
I couldn't I couldn't really say I
couldn't like what could what can I say
for real that's not she don't and that's
also not my Lane so I'm over here that's
over there right I'm going to make some
money I'm gonna tell her like yo I'm not
gonna make this money I don't know what
how you keep how you feel about it but
I'm bringing it back right so I mean I
don't know how mad I could be well I was
going to ask you Jaden because obviously
uh do you have any relationship or have
you ever had any sort of conversations
that were peaceful with Christian
because you guys are going that have
half siblings uh no I don't think we've
ever had no peaceful nothing peaceful no
I think it's always the time no it's not
even a well it's not like I don't know
what he's talking about but
are you interested I'm not interested in
that at all I'm not I'm not interested
in that at all I kind of stay they would
never cross paths they don't know I just
kind of I mean our thing is it's like
you obviously you're gonna have a there
could be half for others that's kind of
that's kind of more so like his
dictation because like he knows how I am
with my kids that's what it is not
changing for because you went and did
that it's not changing what I say is
what I'm going with my kids I don't know
about like would you be opposed to your
kids meeting
you know his baby you know I mean maybe
under his care or my care just not that
person's just not happening but I mean I
can't really that's kind of what that
would kind of be evil of me to like be
like they can never meet like I don't I
I've never had to have like a half
sibling with somebody that my mom didn't
like or something so I don't really know
but you've never had to go today yeah so
I mean but I also don't want to be the
evil Mom that's like you can't see them
like I mean he went and did that it's
like as long as he still goes with what
I am comfortable with I mean what can I
I can't really yeah like I don't really
there's not much I can do for sure you
know what I'm saying like I'm just being
real like that's just you seems like a
pretty reasonable human being I mean you
know like don't cross me but like yeah
it might annoy me like there's things
that I don't want to have to deal with
obviously that was like disappointing
but I don't I can't like sit and change
it so I'm not gonna be the evil one like
no and make it hard for him and make him
want to like do [__] that I wouldn't
like so I mean if I have to if I can
pick and choose I'll do that like do you
have any uh blue face tattoos
yeah I have uh the one on my ass and
then I have his initials right here but
did you have this one too oh yeah and I
have this one you guys yeah it's a
matching tat right yeah I have this one
this one and then the one on my ass
what's the one on your asset it's just
his uh
Jonathan Porter on it no you got the
[__] government
license plate that's interesting
yeah the last time I did an interview
with this guy
my table got [__] up every time no no
no no no
she's so nice